In the last couple of videos
we set a scenario where
company A intends to acquire company B.
Their going to do it by
issuing 2 million shares
and then giving those
2 million shares to the
shareholders of company B, and company B
shareholders will give,
essentially, all of their
ownership away. Their will
be an exchange 2 million
of company A shares for 1
million of company B shares.
On a [per search 0:24] share
basis the owners of company B
will give up one of their
shares, and in exchange
they will get 2 shares of company A.
They will get 2 shares in company.
We saw that if everyone
thought that this transaction
was going to happen,
theoretically, whatever
A is trading at B should
trade at twice that.
People know that they'll
always be a little trade-in,
or when the transaction
happens there be a little
trade-in of B for two of these A shares.
What happens is a
situation, or why would a
situation happen where B
doesn't trade at twice of A?
This is a theoretical trading twice is A.
This is 2 times A.
What happens if it doesn't trade there?
What happens if B's shares are trading ...
let me do this in a color
I haven't used before.
What if it's trading a
little bit lower there?
Well, that might be the
case, because some people
don't think that the
transactions going to happen.
Their not willing to pay that full premium
for B. Let's say that this were to happen,
and you are working at
some type of a hedge fund
that has some type of model,
maybe some mathematical
model, maybe you have some
type of shady information.
Where you know for a fact,
you are 100% certain,
this transaction is going
to close. It's definitely
going to close with these
terms. 2 million shares
of A in exchange for
1 million shares of B.
Your temptation might be,
well, why don't I just
buy these shares of B,
because they will go up.
What if the whole market goes down?
What if the stock of
A goes down like this?
Then 2 times A will also go down.
You don't want to just buy
the stock of B thinking
it's going to go up. If
the transaction is really
going to happen, B is just
going to track 2 times
the price of A.
The best way to do it is
to really set up a bit
of a pair trade here. What
you would do is if you
think the transaction
is definitely happening,
you could buy 1 share ...
let me write this down.
You could buy 1 share of B. Share of B.
You've gone long 1 share
of B. Then you can short
2 shares of A. The reason
why this will work,
and this will only work if you know the
transaction is going to happen, is because
right now 2 shares of
A are going to be ...
at any point since B is trading
a little bit of a discount
to that, the 2 shares of
A are going to be worth
more than that the 1 share of B.
When you sort 2 shares
of A, maybe, where this
point right here ...
let's say that we are at
this point on that day that everything was
announced. When you short
2 shares of A, you're
going to get $60.
You're going to get $60. This is a review.
You borrow the stock,
you sell it, and you're
going have to buy it
back at some future date.
You owe someone 2 shares
of A. When you buy
1 share of B, it's not
going to be trading at $60,
it's going to be trading at some discount.
Let's say that that cost
you $55. It's trading
a little bit of discount to 2 times A.
Clearly just here, you have netted.
$60 minus $55, you have netted $5.
$5 net. Then assuming
the transaction happens
at some future date, when
the transaction closes,
that 1 share of B that
you had, you can exchange
it for 2 shares of A. You get 2 times A.
Then you could use that
to cover your short
position. You use that to cover your short
position, and you're
left standing with $5.
You essentially made ...
well, there is a risk
that the transaction
didn't close, but assuming
the transaction happened,
this was kind of a
[pedima 04:17] free $5 for your taking.